les élèves sont d'ethnie ouïgoure
d'origine turque mais les maîtresses
soran elle parle le mandarin
1992 c'est une des premières fois que la
télévision française s'intéresse à la
communauté ouïghoure une minorité
musulmane en chine pourquoi tout
simplement car un rallye traverser le
sin kiang une région autonome du nord
ouest de la chine
pour voir un reportage sur le sort de
cette minorité il faut attendre
1999 et l'émission géopolis
les ouigours mentent à leurs fins mais
ne se sentent pas chinois ils seront
bientôt moins nombreux que les crânes et
vivre à côté de l'économie moderne comme
exclu chez eux pendant vingt minutes le
journaliste raconte la colonisation des
chinois fan une colonisation
démographique avec un but occuper ce
territoire pour faire taire toute
velléité séparatiste des ouigours car
cette région en plus d'être stratégique
et riche en pétrole et en gaz sur la
grand-place de route chi les ouigours se
sentent de moins en moins chez eux on
imagine sans peine les faits des ports
dépoitraillé du folklore crâne sur les
ouigours musulmans qui passe par là en
plus de cette acculturation des
persécutions sont dénoncés par des
ouïghours qui ont fui la chine sous
prétexte de limiter les naissances à 2
maximum par couple et d'interdire
absolument le troisième enfant on
pratique la stérilisation forcée sur des
centaines de milliers de nos femmes
la médiatisation s'accélère en 2008
lorsque pékin organise les jeux
olympiques si le tour de vis est
identique aux tibétains les ouïghours
n'ont ni dalaï lama ni richard geere
pour le faire savoir
ici en chine nous n'avons aucun droit en
tant que oui aucun droit
nous sommes les esclaves de la chine on
est dominé a servi par les fans l'année
suivante une des premières
manifestations en france
les manifestants demandaient le soutien
du président de la république mais il
faudra attendre 2018 est la preuve que
des camps de travail forcé existent pour
qu'un président français s'exprime
ouvertement la chine priés de fermer ses
camps d'internement à l'onu la france
l'allemagne notamment ont dénoncé mardi
la répression contre les ouïghours
aujourd'hui l'europe menacent de
boycotter les produits issus du travail
forcé sans citer la chine ni les
ouigours le message se veut ferme
reste à savoir si les multinationales
vont réagir elle aussi face à ces
menaces
[Musique]